welcome back joining me now as you can
see the Home Secretary amber a very good
morning and you won't be surprised to
hear I wonder if we can dwell on the
conduct of some of your colleagues first
and and the first that strikes me is
someone we need to discuss this Stephen
crammed and there's someone that should
no longer be in Parliament well there's
something going on across both parties
affecting MPs indeed even ministers and
there was a number of inquiries going on
I think we should let those take place
what is good about this is it's going to
lead to fundamental change what this is
about is the abuse of power it needs to
end and I hope that the Westminster
workplace can make the changes that so
many other workplaces have made so that
men and women can continue to work to
the other with respect
well we certainly didn't know when he
when he resigned from his cabinet
position and what we know no a 19 year
old applied to work in his office he
then sent her sexually explicit text
messages I'm seeing out loud and I can't
quite believe it well there were
allegations have been made it's some MPs
and Stephen is one of them are having
that matter looked into I think we have
to be careful not to jump to conclusions
and feel yourself as conceded that they
were sexual in nature he sent them to
someone who applied for a job in his
office prima facie that's not something
that an MP should be doing absolutely it
isn't but it's up to it's up to the
Prime Minister and the procedures that
are put in place to decide what sort of
action is taken following that but there
are times when you know that when the
title right honourable become something
of a hollow joke and this is one of them
I can't think of any other profession
where you know if you invite someone in
for a job and then what to send them
text you do remain in your post why is
he still an MP really really you can't
think of any other profession you don't
think this has been going on across
different workplaces across the country
internationally this is a watershed
moment in Westminster what's the highest
and we do people who work in a call
center I'm just I'm just it's not just a
call said I'm just picking you up on the
fact that this isn't unique to
Westminster we should hold ourselves to
a higher standard and I want us to do
that which is why we're going to be
making changes but this isn't just
unique to Westminster
this is about a fundamental change in
the way power even in authority is
exercised we will be making those change
and we want other people to make them
too I mean we had a similar argument
earlier on from from the shadow foreign
secretary this is not a problem that is
confined to Parliament and demonstrable
that's true but it but it does seem when
there is such a focus or on the
activities of parliamentarians or party
members a better buck-passing to suggest
actually do you know what this is a
societal problem you know widows guilty
of it as anyone else so but we need to
heal all of society rather than in no
way is anybody trying to pass the buck
this is incredibly important and the
fact that it's taking place at
Westminster is shocking and it's even
more important that it changes there but
I think that the buck needs to be imaged
to be admitted that the buck is wider
than just Westminster it's not unique to
us doesn't mean it's not important it's
absolutely essential we make the changes
okay I'm not another individual that I
think we need to talk about is Michael
Fallon no the initial accusation that
was made against them seems to have
morphed in some people's minds - you
know it was a bit of a touch of any
actually what happened according to
Julia Hartley Brewer is that he in a
sexual manner groped her leg a number of
times to the extent that she felt the
need to tell him get your hands off me
or I'm going to punch you why is he
still an MP well Michael Thielen has
made a statement and he has resigned
from his position as Minister I think
he's made it absolutely clear what his
view is and I think it's right that he
resigned but that's that he doesn't
resign from his job he stepped down from
the post of Defence actually his job is
Member of Parliament again I get this
like this impression that you know we
are supposed to look up to our
politicians and every time we do we see
something you know you're pretty
disgusting and in fact he didn't resign
over the Julie Hartley Brewer
accusations we know no and a Sabri this
morning confirming it was because of the
accusation made by Jayne Merrick a
junior political correspondent at the
time that after a lunch with her she was
just doing this job he lunged at her
it's disgusting I agree completely
disgusting absolutely wrong and it was
right that he has stepped out he's made
his statement about what he believes was
the right thing to do and as a result of
that and other disclosed situations
allegations some of which are turning
out to be correct some of which we don't
know there will be full change
Westminster but not at his office not in
his parliamentary office he still see
there and in fact you mean you met you
mentioned that the kind of the
confessional that he gave to the media
actually in that he appeared to suggest
you know these events took place 10-15
years ago it was a different time it
wasn't it wasn't a different time no I
mean I completely agree that the sort of
behavior that he talked about and that
we have been talking about is
unacceptable now and in my opinion it
was unacceptable thirty years ago but
what we're doing now is making changes
to make sure that we change not just the
regulations not just the sources of how
people can appeal but the culture and
the way you change the culture is to
have more women in office as well these
things take place where you have a place
where which is completely male-dominated
and where Parliament used to be like
that like perhaps trading floors in the
city then you have that sort of abuse
that needs to change but it strikes me
again we have someone who there is prima
facie case he should not be a member of
parliament I mean come on if a male
journalist having had lunch with you
lunged at you he'd be out of a job
immediately his feet wouldn't touch the
floor so why is the one rule for a
politician and one real friend well I I
just don't accept that I don't accept
you don't accept it
we're gonna take we're gonna take this
take me in you out of this particular
picture workplaces have proper sources
for people to go to proper procedures
that's what they need to do Parliament
hasn't had those proper procedures in
place yet it needs to those are the
changes were making not before time I
agree with that it feels like Parliament
has been slow to put that in place
that's why it's so important that we do
it as part of that process then do you
concede that there needs to be a
mechanism by which someone can be sacked
from their posters Member of Parliament
I think that that is one of the things
that I would encourage the review to
look at it may be the case it may not
but it is wrong what's your view it is
wrong for us to have a knee-jerk
reaction based on the past week I think
that what we need to do is look at the
whole issue there needs to be a
procedure put in place as soon as
possible but the consequences of
misbehavior of the sort we've been
looking at this week there needs to be a
proper look at what action needs to be
taken after that I want to move on Notre
Dame in green and and frankly you know
the stories that are around this morning
he denies them as indeed he denies the
stories that are previously that he's
previously
been linked to that that is out there no
shouldn't he be stepping down from the
Cabinet Office well while this this
investigation by the Cabinet Office is
ongoing he's how many committed cabinet
committees is he currently sitting on he
strongly denies these allegations
let's give him time and the inquiry time
to make sure that he has the opportunity
to put it straight what he believes was
the case I really look forward to him
clearing his name he would have more
time if he won't sitting you know I
can't have a situation where any
allegation that is made somebody
immediately has to resign because we
don't know what substance that isn't any
of these allegations as I say he
strongly denies them mmm some people ask
why women often feel feeling unable to
speak out the treatment of Kate montly
you know Damien Greene's accuser gives
give gives one answer this is the The
Daily Mail's
response well it's in fact it's on our
screen we'll try and get it into the
screen in a second what did you make of
that what did you make of the treatment
of Kate more by this paper read by
millions every day I think that women
should have the courage to come forward
and make their statements where they
feel there is something important to be
said as Kate clearly did so I think that
we need to make sure that all women and
indeed sometimes men are able to come
forward and be courageous as they have
been to step up and say this is what
happened but it's disgusting isn't it
Italy no I'm not going to be drawn on
commenting on individual cases about
this what I want to make sure is that
there are we live in an environment
where there's respect for men and women
and where women or men can come forward
and make their tell tell people what
happened in a way that allows them to
deal with the sort of abuse we've been
talking about do you worry about people
being unfairly accused I mean you're
introducing a new compulsory code of
conduct and that in and of itself would
not stop folks accusations being made
well but there's always going to be the
potential for false accusations but that
doesn't mean we shouldn't have in place
a really rigorous protocol process so
that people can have somewhere to go to
make sure that they are listened to
that's the key thing hmm the fact is in
each of those instances that we've been
discussing you know the Whip's office
knew about these things before the
public I mean you've this morning said
you know that it is time for
disclosure so the Whip's office to hand
over that information when should that
happen bike when should the Prime
Minister nor everything that they do
well I've also said that I spent a year
in a whips office and I don't recognize
some of these stories about the sort of
information that whips apparently have
what I recognized in the Whip's office
is our duty to get government business
through listen I do think that we should
have a situation where people are much
more transparent about the information
that is held and needs to be shared so
in answer to your question of course the
Whip's office should share the
information with the Prime Minister but
I'm also saying that there isn't the
sort of black book in operations there's
sometimes suggested that that is fine
but can I get an assurance that if that
information is passed to the Prime
Minister if there are any allegations of
criminality they will be immediately
passed to the police if any allegations
of criminality should be passed to the
police irrespective of who's holding
them of course indeed there is a very
real possibility if this this scandal
continues that people will take the
route that mr. Crabb
you know sir Michael have chosen not to
and actually step down as members of
parliament if that happens I mean the
Conservatives could lose that that the
working majority that you have what
happens at that point Parliament is an
extraordinary and fantastic place for
most people to live and work there is a
small minority of people who have
behaved badly sometimes as we look at
these allegations very seriously
but we need to make sure that we
continue to attract people into
Parliament and I want to make sure that
more women have confidence about coming
into Parliament I think the government
has made those changes is making those
changes and can I also just say it's not
the only thing we're doing but on the
topic that I've just asked you if the
government loses its majority what then
I mean could we potentially see an early
election I mean we've got reports this
morning that you the government is
preparing for a by-election yes I have
no knowledge about that what I do know
and I do think it's important to make
this point because I know that everybody
is talking about this issue of
individuals and allegations but I just
want to reassure viewers that we are
also getting on with the important
business of government of delivering on
our agenda of making sure in my case
that I work hard to keep people safe
online and offline a few days ago the
association of police and crime
commissioners suggested that you need an
extra 440 million pounds 2018-19
845 million 2019
20 and yet your response was to suggest
that guys don't keep asking for money
every time the crime stats go up my
response was to say I recognized there
are pressures on our own police in terms
of the changes in crime pressures as
well well in terms of the growth in
terrorism that we've had this week
that's what increased pressure on them
but I also saying to them it's not just
about that it's about the powers that we
give you to make sure that you can
deliver on reducing crime and keeping
people safe I have recognized and
acknowledged that crime has been
changing and we're working to make sure
they have the right training the right
powers and yes the right resources to
address that I mean it's also been
rising as sardath aunt and chair of the
national police chiefs council said
before you made your speech for quality
crime up by 13% record levels of 99 9
calls the police services stretched our
staff are feeling that and the public is
noticing it I mean do you disagree with
that characterization well I just want
to point out the difference between
recorded crime and actual crime she
distinguished herself in her speech
recorded crime has gone up and that's
because we are encouraging people to
report as we were saying earlier in our
conversation I want people to have the
confidence to come forward and report
crime so that action can be taken but
actual crime you know people who have
victims of crime has come down a third
since 2010 and that's because of the
amazing work of our police are you sure
that you are giving the police enough
money to do their job we will always
give the police the right resources to
do their job they have made certain
issues a priority and I recognize that
and I've said we're going to look
carefully what else we can do but I
don't just want them coming to me and
doing press releases about money I want
to make sure that they have the right
tools the right power the right training
to reduce crime now or less money no not
less money we've frozen the budget
between 2015 and 2020 take cuts they
have not what we've done is put some
money into a transformation fund but
we're forces maximize their precept
they're able to make sure that they have
a steady income going forward in terms
of the real amount of money going to the
forces on secretary penny thanks for
being with us thank you